vous n'avez pas écouté on n'a perdu
qu'un banal s'il est tellement dans le
jeu qui ne peuvent pas revenir
il a pris ce cache cache très à coeur je
savais pas qu il a fallu me flinguer la
table et je ne savais pas que tu jouais
pas il faut bien qu'un arbitre mais pas
besoin arabe là bas c'est pas une tenue
à jouer celle d'unica gg si si si demain
les gars non non non ce serait tout à
une tenue veille qui a vu la mentalité
française médical ne détecte pas que je
crois aux chances de jeu ouais c'est
vrai alors osez à bertoua première
tranche et la crise n'est pas résolue
maillard non mais record de 3 soleil
[Applaudissements]
agathe alors eh ben c'est la première
fois parce que là ça va commencer à
tourner l'émission l'avait et sans ça va
tourner et qu'on fasse qu'en cas d'
aller chez l'émission le fait vous avez
en dépôt direct sur d8 c'est la première
fois je vous jure que c'est vrai qu'on
va faire un cache-cache géant non
c'est pas la même chose
[Applaudissements]
d
je vous explique les règles je vais
sortir je vais sortir je vais compter
jusqu'à 20
vous allez tous vous cacher sur le
plateau le premier j'ai côté le site
le premier que je trouve je le fous d'or
d'accord j'avais compté là bas c'est
parti venez avec moi
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mettez la joie bien sûr des vitres c'est
la première fois qu'on fait un casque un
gymnase une émission la foutaise
émission n'était pas en revanche
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il aime bagages été trouvé j'en ai
trouvé
j'en ai trouvé il faut que j'ai trop tôt
mais quoi monte monte monte monte monte
on dit regardez regardez la dernière
j'en ai trouvé deux j'en ai trouvé de
jean michel lemaire trouvé c'est bon tu
trouve des brochets ans michel mr
trouver attention attention les gars on
doit rendre l'antenne ya les a connus
après mais bon la cas du journal qui
arrive avec derrick également il est élu
quelle heure c'est pour ça 20h38 alors
attendez je suis sûr que j'en ai vu une
là j'en ai vu une mise à personne by
naim les genres alors oui léogâne je
cherche gad elmaleh gad elmaleh gad
elmaleh qu'un nom alors déjà là
connaître chaque roue effet trouvé merci
s'est trouvée attendait alors ensuite
qu'est ce qui nous manque si vous nous
rejoignez nous sommes en plein
cache-cache l égard
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mais c'est formidable je me suis régalé
n'y a qu' à l'heure ce que je peux vous
dire c'est que les autres ou gageons que
c'est cool les autres gagner il faut
revenir
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
élément club à la demande comme à la
ville et au canada à cowes et étonné
parce qu'il est très jeune j'espère
j'espère qu'ils j'ai très peur pour lui
madame c ou fully il est ok valence je
sais pas vous mais ils n'ont pas écouté
on n'a perdu qu'à madame s'il est
tellement dans le jeu qui ne veut pas
revenir
il a pris ce cache cache très à coeur
car adams va durer non les gars je vous
dira oui c'est sûr y'a qu'à mi combat
qui parvient sombre il a juste lors des
marathons tu démarres quand la le
tournage les
[Applaudissements]
non parce qu'ils demandent quand tu
démarres le tournoi on va la faire cette
émission jusqu'à excusez moi il est hors
cac van hamme ce million cavale mais on
l'a trouvé
[Applaudissements]